trolls were very large and monstrous
raids ranging from between 10 to 50 feet
tall and for the most part unintelligent
humanoid race inhabiting middle-earth
although there are some that are
considered sentient and capable of
high-level speech regarding the history
of trolls melkor created trolls before
the first age they were very strong but
turn into stone in sunlight many trolls
died in the war of Wrath but some
survived and joined the forces of Sauron
the greatest surviving servant of
Morgoth in a second and third Age trolls
were among Sorrows most dangerous
warriors DM Treebeard says that the
trolls were made a mockery of ends as
orcs were of elves though not
necessarily from ng stock however they
could be based on another race of
middle-earth as neither Morgoth nor
Sauron had access to the secret fire and
therefore cannot create things only also
that which already exists during the
Wars of balerion got from up the law of
bow rocks had a bodyguard of trolls
while leading his men in a final stand
to project the retreat of turgon and the
continued secrecy of the kingdom of
Gondolin the great warrior and faced
them and due to marcus emphatic orders
to have herein captured alive
he managed to kill many of them in
Rankin and bass animated movies trolls
here assured us large humanoids
apparently of mammalian nature with
large noses and tusks however other than
Tom Worth and William several crawls and
armor are seen in the siege of Gondor in
The Return of the King as melee fighters
and as operators of the battering ram
grown in Ralph Bakshi's 1978 animated
version it follows the book very
faithfully in his depiction of the
encounter with a troll in the chamber
however the troll does have those here
from parts of it seem through the door
it seems to be of humanoid reptilian
around 9 feet tall in Peter Jackson's
logs the Rings and later in the Hobbit
trilogy there are many types of trolls
there was seen so all in all how many
types of trolls exists in middle-earth
and what are their defining features and
characteristics it is stated for a fact
that they are all together seven species
or types in all the movies and games
number one the Ola hi
they were depicted as large trolls in
the motion picture the Lord of the Rings
The Return of the King clad in dark
armor and wielding the war hammers
alluded to in the appendices in the
siege of Gondor they were primarily used
as shock troops after the gates of Minas
Tirith were broken although later and
all of high duels Eragon at the Black
Gate and nearly kills him they differ
from other trolls depicted in movies in
that they have more forward-facing eyes
as well as hair on their bodies they are
usually gray dark green reddish brown or
black in color they have 24 teeth and
have an average height of about 10 to 15
feet compared to the regular trolls who
were eight to ten feet tall in the
Hobbit film adaptations most
specifically in The Hobbit the Battle of
the five armies sarang's chief of
lieutenant Azov commands a few dozen
armored Olaf high dog gold along with
thousands of war bred Moria orcs in this
film the Olaf's appear much like needed
in the law of the Rings trilogy however
there are some key differences most of
the trolls are much larger than any
other variety seen thus far starting
about 25 to 30 feet tall rather than
understand at 10 to 15 feet height of
most all of High's these trolls are
mostly dark gray and tan in color number
two the cave trolls they were arrays of
trolls found within the caves of Misty
Mountains one of them appears in the
Fellowship of the Ring as a fellowship
pass through Moria and a battle of the
Chamber of Master Bull and Peter
Jackson's 2001 movie version there is
one cave troll which is killed by the
fellowship members who spear and hack
the cave troll to no avail and illegal
US dispatches it with an arrow the arrow
enters the roof of its mouth and goes
straight to trolls brain emerging from
the back of its head after becoming
stuck in a trolls
thick skull normally an arrow even elven
wouldn't deal that much damage when seen
up close it also has a set of nostrils
located higher than the space between
its eyes making them look more
like a third eye these trolls were very
big in size and were in the range of 15
to 18 feet tall around 4 to 5 point 5
meters in height as compared to the lot
of the Rings all up high which are just
over 15 feet tall not only that but
their durability is very high as being
able to withstand attacks from the
fellowship number 3 forest trolls they
are extremely large trolls that live in
the small forest around Rivendell has
discovered by Bilbo on his quest to the
Lonely Mountain they are so sensitive to
sunlight that they're instantly turned
to stone if exposed to it they are
believed to be the most intelligent race
of trolls to live being the only one
being capable of speech aside from Tom
bird and William in the two towers video
game 5 forest trolls are seen although
four are in daylight and not turned to
stone
also many are seen in the law of the
Rings arrogance quest all in daylight
and alive they could be anywhere between
30 to 50 feet tall or around 9 to 15
meters in height forest trolls might be
the ones that the N stated as being
created in mockery of them by Morgoth
but then again these trolls only appear
later on in the games and would never
describe or talk about in Tolkien's
works number 4 stone trolls stone trolls
were trolls turn to stone by daylight
like the trolls in The Hobbit because of
this they had to seek sanctuary in hosts
to escape the stony fate they could
speak and used a debased form of Western
rendered into cockney English in The
Hobbit Tom Burton William Huggins were
three stone trolls at Bilbo Baggins
encountered in the troll jaws in area
door while with Thorin and company on
the quest to regain the Lonely Mountain
which is Erebor like most of their kind
outside of Mordor they were vagabonds
who robbed stole and killed for what
they needed or wanted their age is
unknown but they were destroyed by
sunlight which turned them to stone with
the aid of Gandalf trickery on the way
to Rivendell Eragon and the four hobbits
Frodo Sam wise Mary and peregrin took
and counted to three trolls that had
been turned to stone 77 years previously
and the hobbits momentarily thought them
to be alive they all stand around 13
feet tall
four metres in height number five snow
trolls snow trolls were one of several
troll subspecies and I only mentioned
once in Tolkien's worlds in reference to
helm hammerhand stopping his enemies
like a snow troll during his stories
against the done landings in the long
winter snow trolls are mentioned only in
the story of helm hammerhand when he'll
went out with gladden white during the
long winter to stop and slay his enemies
as he was described as looking like a
snow troll otherwise nothing of them is
known the trolls who live in the cold
fells in western arid or may have been
similar to these not much is known about
their size and whether they are related
or maybe I just Mountain trolls or cave
trolls that stay in colder areas where
snow is abundant they appear in two
games and are now canon to middle-earth
snow trolls are depicted in the rise of
the witch-king the expansion pack to
love the Rings the Battle of malala's
two shorter trolls from Anwar who
maneuver quickly and will large pickaxes
number six mountain trolls they were a
very large type of troll that were
closely related to cave trolls and Hill
trolls they were allies of orcs like all
trolls mountain trolls originated from
Morgause twisting and crossbreeding
of other creatures of the world and
later became minions of Sauron modern
trolls could be found in the mountains
of middle-earth their type help move the
great battering ram grown into place
during the battle of the pelennor fields
which they we lit and shadowed the large
gates of ministerials with it members of
the species will also see an opening the
gates of the Black Gate the modern
trolls make dangerous opponents in
battle these trolls are smaller than
cave trolls and their power to lift
massive objects to use as weapons make
them deadly they are assumed to be
strong enough for other heavy tasks as
well they are stronger than cave trolls
due to their harsh environment they
stand over twenty to thirty feet in
height and are as big as the Olaf high
from the Hobbit movies
number seven half-truths half truths
were a very little-known of race that
came from Farhad who were loyal to
Sauron Tolkien mentions them only once
or twice they appeared in the battle of
the pelennor fields alongside the other
man allies of Sauron it is unknown of
which two races they are a hybrid off
half draws appear in the law of the
rings the bell of middle-earth stew
goblins ox and yokai were all created
for the express purpose of war by the
dark powers is from this wicked
tradition that the half trolls were also
born by crossing a troll in an Hall they
came into existence a rare but hefty
breed of warrior while trolls are strong
but stupid and goblins are numerous but
frail the Marauders was strong and
clever enough to eke out an existence
wandering the empty ways of the north as
a race hunted by the clever June 18
warriors the Marauders never found peace
on their own and as such their numbers
remain few it was in this way that the
goblins pressed a half-frozen into
service of war the Marauders were
welcomed into caverns of the Misty
Mountains upon the condition that they
would dawn the twisted metal arm of the
Goblin army and fight when they are
called upon now
the goblins deployed the Marauders where
they fight best in open battle against
large opponents such as cavalry the half
troll Saltzman who only appear in the
game's expansion the rise of the
witch-king are similar to the Marauders
but have sauce instead of pikes they
have helmets and armor that are the same
as the Marauders but more night like
than goblin like so this brings us to
the end of the list and hope you enjoyed
the video do click on a notification
bell for actual notifications whenever
we post new stuff rather than just
finding it randomly in the suggested
videos so Mikey and subscribe as well